you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
this video will help you understand what
it is and why it's important to keep it
under control
type two diabetes is a condition in
which your blood sugar level is too high
carbohydrates are substances your body
uses to make energy after you eat food
that contains carbohydrates it
eventually goes to your small intestine
in your small intestine the food is
broken down into single sugar molecules
called glucose the cells in your small
intestine soak up the sugars which pass
into your bloodstream when the blood
reaches your pancreas it detects the
high amount of sugar in your blood
normally this causes your pancreas to
put a chemical called insulin into your
bloodstream the insulin reduces the
amount of sugar in your blood to a
healthy level
how does insulin do this as the blood
moves through your body the insulin and
sugar exit the blood stream into your
tissues to reach your cells most cells
have structures on their surfaces called
insulin receptors when insulin flows by
it attaches to the receptors the insulin
acts like a key in a lock to open up the
cell
so the sugar can get inside now your
cell can use the sugar to make the
energy it needs to work properly and
your blood sugar level drops back to its
normal range
if you have type-2 diabetes your cells
don't respond to insulin as they should
this is called insulin resistance when
this happens your insulin cannot unlock
the cells to let sugar in because the
locks or insulin receptors are missing
or aren't working
as a result sugar is locked out of your
cells
when sugar can't get into your cells it
builds up in your bloodstream this is a
condition called hyperglycemia
in response to the high blood sugar
levels your pancreas makes more and more
insulin the overworked cells in your
pancreas try to keep up
but they slowly lose their ability to
make enough insulin these problems may
lead to the symptoms of type 2 diabetes
if you have questions about type 2
diabetes or any medications you have
been prescribed speak with your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed by your doctor tell him or
her about any side effects you have